[Music]  more new faces i see  [Music]  those things ain't repair and decent  or unfair  they're locals  in other  [Music]  a bit of words dress is in order  if someone's wiping those universes out  one by one  hmm  they'll get their hands on enough power  to wipe out the whole trinity in a snap  thank you professor  [Music]  with all those eyes  i think you'd be a bit more perceptive  [Music]  i believe you two have already met  [Music]  let's go this world is under my  protection  their  homunculi man-made bio-weapons  look we don't have time  if we don't stop them this world is  history and reality is we know it gets  wiped out for good  and what do you expect us to do  i want you to find a scientist named  sigurd  he's somewhere in this world and he can  help us  if we met before  i think i'd remember you riot girl  someone seems very interested in our  arrival is it him  [Music]  lesson one  carelessness will get your tail snipped  kitty  my name  is viola  [Music]  oh  [Music]